what's up everyone welcome back for
another comic-con 2022 interview i've
got some of the team behind the new
series the resort with us i've watched
about half and then i forced myself to
stop because i started to panic that i
might slip and say something too soon
this is a very unique twisty tourney
show and i love it
thank you very much yeah
what do you mean when you say have half
of the first four episodes of the half
of the show no half of the show okay
i stopped at the end of episode four
meet season yeah they think they haven't
got twist did you scream at the end of
episode four the only reason i didn't
scream out loud is because i have
comic-con like brain and energy at this
point and i wasn't able to scream when i
finished it at like three in the morning
but
i'm like teetering into spoiling things
the end of that episode was very very
effective i will tell you that
it's thank you even with that spoiler no
one i don't think anyone can guess where
it goes after oh definitely i don't
think so nobody will be able to guess
anything that happens in this show even
as you're sitting through every single
episode i really was very impressed by
how many genres you mash up into this
thing and how effective it is and
speaking of that andy i was reading some
quotes that you gave about having the
hopes of having made something that felt
like a big summer movie that mashed up
all these different genres and you've
had that dream for a while but why did
now prove to be the right time for the
resort um
because i don't know they they let me do
it i think palm springs probably helped
with that
and to get the permission to to give it
a shot and
um
peacock was the the first one to bite
and
back in the day it was always uh all my
favorite movies were universal movies
and i pretty sure
they're all in the same family it's all
owned by comcast i'm pretty sure uh and
uh so it's nice to be able to like
do that big summer kind of
tent holy blockbuster um on a still
small indie budget uh
uh under the like universal and peacock
umbrella so is there anything you're
able to accomplish on this series that
makes you think if i didn't have all of
my prior experience i wouldn't have been
able to do this specific thing now like
where if you did get the opportunity to
make this earlier in your career you
wouldn't have been able to do it as
successfully as you did i mean
earlier in my career i was just like in
a you know in a van touring the country
in a in a little indie rock band so i
definitely couldn't have done anything
uh you know ten years ago um i'd say uh
yeah there's i don't think anything that
any of this could have been done uh
prior to we'll we'll see if any of it
actually works now uh uh but i don't
think anything any of this could have
been done um prior to any other jobs
that i had so can confirm it works have
faith okay so thank you
thank you so much
again this is this is a show with a
whole lot of twists and turns i'm
curious what is the biggest difference
between what you thought your character
would turn out to be when you first
auditioned for the role and then who
they become as you learn more and more
about the journey they were going to go
on yeah i mean um i had no idea because
i only got one scene and it made no
sense for me i was like what is this how
do i play this how do i even
have i
something closer um
not as crazy as it was i did my audition
with by the way i think it was the worst
audition ever it was it was wonderful
i was like no there's no way i'm getting
a call back and then i got a call back
why did you think it was the worst
audition because i had no idea sometimes
when i look at a script i know what
which way it's going to go and then you
know i do something and it's like well
this is what i what i see this is what i
read on the script but this time i was
reading and i was like what is this it
makes no sense what is yellowstone what
um so i didn't know i guessed the tone
but i didn't know
whether it was gonna it's right tone and
i was right because there isn't one tone
it's like a mix of a lot of things so
and it's crazy and and i was right
because what i was reading
but then how do you address that the
audition process fascinates me i want to
squeeze it one more question about that
what is it like walking out of an
audition not being happy with what you
deliver but by then finding out that the
creator likes what you did and then kind
of merging that together for the next
part of the process that's crazy because
as soon as i got a call back i was i
looked at that tape and i was like
trying to figure out why am i on a call
back if this is
like it's the best surprise i think like
you go in and you don't think you do
well and then suddenly you get another
chance like and especially when the
script is good and you feel like you
screwed up the audition and then you get
another chance to do it and then you
have to hold tight to whatever you
thought was a screw-up because it works
it's true that's true but
you can still play you're always the
worst judge of that you know like you
should never think that much about that
because it's not in your control we're
all always our own worst critics yeah
yes were you going to jump in andy i was
just going to say that like
your audition tape didn't actually
matter because there was several people
in the writers room that brought you up
and then when we said that you did
audition we're like oh we should just
see if she wants to do it
so the tape didn't the tape was great
but uh we're they're fans of you already
headed out the i think she's a really
great movie uh la camaresta that is like
top notch and that's why uh we wanted
her to be in it so um so
you're too hard on yourself i love it uh
i will continue down the line with that
question from earlier which i hope i can
remember what is the biggest difference
between the character when you first
auditioned for the role and who they
turned out to be as you dug into them a
little more well um
thank god this was one of my first
offers in the us and he wrote me a
really beautiful letter being like man i
saw your work in this movie and in this
show and i would love you to play this
character which is one of the leads of
the show and it's very important then he
sent me the first two scripts
where i wasn't barely in them and i was
like uh i'm not i'm not in this in the
scenes at all and he was like no you
need to trust me the first two episodes
is just like a setup for your character
but after episode 3 it's all about you
it's all about you just trust me and and
i did and it was it was it was it was
right but at the beginning it was very
scary being like maybe i've been tricked
by this guy
and i'm just going to be a well-paid
extra in this eight episodes in puerto
rico for four months but it was really
it was really cool and also very tricky
because our characters are like um
like the bridge before the past and the
present you know like these guys live in
the golden days of the resort when the
resort was beautiful and perfect and
they were
building this family and doing these
drugs for the first time and having
these parties for the first time and
they are the bridge to the present where
after this horrible thing happened and
they're trying to solve the mystery with
uh noah
and emma the characters from christine
and um and will so i think uh
building that bridge was very
interesting and also tricking the
audience all the time you know because
at the beginning you need to think
there's something shady about these two
and it might not be true or or maybe it
is i don't know but but playing with
those misleading directions all the time
that was that was an interesting part of
the job i keep ruining the flow here but
i want to follow up on that how do you
figure out how much to kind of play into
the mystery where you're trying to build
it up for the audience
as opposed to i guess playing the truth
of the character that you know is going
to wind up being the case in the end it
has to be both that's that's the tricky
part like you need to be able to do all
those misleading things but at the end
of the day after seeing the whole show
that need to make sense with your
character because otherwise as an
audience you're gonna be like uh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] you know and and i think
that's a tricky thing doing from the
writers from the writers room but also
being very honest and truthful to what
you're doing in every single scene you
know i'm not thinking that much about
what's gonna happen in four episodes all
right nina you're finally up
that last question that we asked like 10
minutes ago
uh no yeah i think i think violet from
like the first episode she just gets
more and more complex i think you learn
a lot about her and uh murray and nick
offerman's character in the second
episode and you kind of see
why she's
in this place and when i got the first
episode i was again kind of like louise
like i wasn't
i was in it at like the very end and
then
it's
it's a wild ride and i think
it was really exciting getting to know
her more and more because
uh
her
her story mimics a lot of my own life
currently so that was really
bizarre and like a weird mystical
universe
thing to have it come into my life
right now i must follow up how so yeah
um i mean in the show violet's dealing
with the loss of her mother and
a month prior i had lost my father and
i don't want to spoil much of what
happens but
there's something else that violet is
given
um
kind of as a gift from her mom and i had
a very similar
gift from my own dad that uh has taken
me and my family on a journey so it's
been pretty crazy and spectacular how
you know intertwined
we were um yeah i'm sorry for your loss
but that's some beautiful connectivity
there
um andy i'm coming back your way so
again we've already covered this a whole
bunch of genre mash-ups happening here
is there any particular genre that you
tap into that you found the hardest to
either write to begin with or bring to
screen ultimately it's funny i don't
really think uh
i don't think so much about the genre
stuff it's uh it's i feel like as long
as the tone is
uh consistent and i think our tone is
constantly
going from silly to sincere and
it's it's really it's a hard line to
balance on because sometimes we can get
too silly and sometimes we get a little
too like a little too like melodramatic
so we always want to undercut it with
like the goofiness um and so but i feel
like as long as we are we have control
over that you can kind of like jump
around to any genres kind of like with
ease and a lot of it's just to like keep
me entertained in the writing process i
get bored very easily in life uh and uh
and but on its very practical level the
hardest part hardest one was
there's some disaster film elements to
this and that's just it's hard to do a
disaster film uh and those were the like
just on on a scale some of the
it's still small scale for the show but
those were the hardest things to
actually pull off uh production wise um
yeah in terms of those tonal shifts when
can you gauge for yourself when it's
working best at what part in the process
can you feel in the script does it have
to be when you see your actors working
with the material on set or is it not
until it's all edited together um i'd
say like i i
following my gut along in the script
it's like it seems like it's good enough
and then teaming up with ben sinclair
who i think has a for who directed the
first four episodes and he has the same
kind of like everything has to have
comedy comedy in it uh and like in high
maintenance he can make me laugh and cry
in the same like five minute scene um
and so that's like so i i feel it there
but it's even as we were shooting from
like you know uh february march through
may we were constantly kind of looking
at each other like is this gonna work i
don't know um and it wasn't until seeing
it in seeing in the edit that i was like
okay now it's working i feel like you
don't wind up with a special end product
if you're not asking yourself like is
this gonna work while you're on set
otherwise you're probably doing a carbon
copy of something else yeah it wasn't it
really was until the edit that we we saw
that it was uh okay this we we we got it
so you should be proud so you did you
did thus far at least i can't speak to
the full show but i have lots of faith
because i really do like the first four
episodes okay so for the three of you
now
working with again all of these genres
but also the the twists and turns and
the narrative what's a core quality of
each of your character where even if
things get zany even if they make a
really impulsive decision you know you
could always come back to that core
quality as like an anchor to know their
decisions are made in in like a truth to
the character
do you want to start are you ready i'm
ready go for it
i i think it i mean um i think it was a
blessing to have played
two stages of this character 15 years
back and 15 years forward i mean present
so
in that sense i think
what you realized that have changed for
me that was my anchor because i was
thinking what was she thinking 15 years
ago who was this person 15 years ago
because even if i and i brought it to
myself i was like who was your brother
15 years ago and i didn't recognize
myself like from the person i am now so
i put that into luna and i thought
okay maybe
she she was this this and this but in
her present
family is what matters the most
you know and
she's now a mother and she's now um
she's married so
i think now you have to put that into
balance yeah the golden years were
amazing but now
you have your present and your present
it's it's great too and
the most important i think it's family
at the end of the day that's a beautiful
answer now you two have to top that
um
i think it's about
proving proving the world that he's
enough like proving the world that he
can solve this mystery you know this
this character is he comes from this
really powerful family in yucatan uh and
he doesn't want to belong to that family
anymore he needs to create
uh
a new version of himself and and he's
obsessed with detective novels and he
wants to be the best detective in the
world and the first time he got a really
a real case
he cannot solve it and now he have the
opportunity of doing of doing that 15
years
later so there's always this really big
desire of of proving that he's enough
which i think is really moving and sad
and i think every one of us can relate
to that feeling in a way so i think that
was like um
an easy clue
clue to follow you know yeah i bet for
your nina yeah i mean i think violet is
really
fearless and kind of marches
to her own like tune and and
um
i think within that i think as as the
show
goes on it gets wilder and wilder and i
think just trusting because she's she's
grieving so i think
trusting that like grief is is messy and
i think this is your 20s are messy and
just kind of combining
both of those things and then dealing
with uh sam skyler josonna's character
on top of that like
them together just
kind of rooting into that that messiness
all right andy i have a big question for
you that makes me feel like a big old
jerk for asking it because it makes me
feel greedy because we haven't even seen
the full season yet but i had read a
quote a while back that when you
conceived of the show the plan was to
make it i guess an anthology series of
sorts where each season takes place in a
different location
is that still the plan and do you have a
next location in mind
um
ask uh ask peacock okay
yeah i mean i i can uh if we want to
keep it going there's ways to keep it
going but this i'd say that the
the mysteries and the questions that are
set in in this season uh everything is
answered so it is a very uh it's a very
closed end kind of thing okay i'm a big
believer in manifesting so i feel like
it's okay that i asked that question
um i didn't get a rap sign yet so i'm
gonna play a game unless someone yells
at me i love a game all right so
this is my favorite game to play because
i love horror movies i'm basically gonna
turn the set of the resort into a
slasher movie so i'm going to give you
guys a slasher movie cliche and i need
you to tell me which actor best suits
this description okay and you can call
out anyone who's not here they'll never
share a
i'm sorry i'm not a native speaker
movie is like like scream and michael
myers okay you gotta go all right
oh i don't like it
it's all fake i promise so you're on set
a mass killer is running around your set
who is most likely to not realize that
they're in a horror movie and being
stalked by a killer and go and
investigate a strange noise and be the
first to die
skyler skyler yeah
why skyler
he likes to go off on his own a lot he's
not here right now yeah right
we would just be like on set and
suddenly he'd just disappear somewhere
yeah he heard about a good buffet down
the street totally yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's out of there yeah he's
the guy that he's not aware that his the
mic of his phone is open when he's
saying something really inappropriate
yeah he doesn't know his uh yeah
he's on he's on camera hi skyler we love
you we still love you this all lines up
pretty well here's here's a more
positive one
who is the most likely to sacrifice
themselves for the group
i want to say
i want to say nick offerman yeah yeah
yeah
super super kind and generous yeah and
he's also the oldest one so he had a he
had a nice life already longer
definitely
yeah yeah
i will sacrifice him
i will be like me go
i have yet to hear someone put that spin
on it i am amused
most likely to trip and fall while
running from the killer wheel
really yeah
all the time yeah well
wow
did that happen on this set no you know
i can see will doing that now i can i
thought it was me but
yeah no but i think you have more
qualities with your body that will yeah
thank you
here's my favorite one who is the first
to basically say like
f this it's too scary i'm not even
staying around for this i'm leaving and
just walk off andy
100
i totally disagree i disagree too yeah i
think that's also will too
i think yeah i think we love you
absolutely
that's a great quality yeah there was
there was a scene where we had a
helicopter and helicopter landing and uh
he was like shaking to the core of how
scary he was about this helicopter
crashing or whatever but it was really
far away it did it never felt dangerous
for any of us but he was like are we
done with this are we done with this so
yeah i just wanted to go on the
helicopter
like no no way and i'm like i would have
been right there with you yeah send me
in that helicopter put me in a plane and
let me jump out of it please
um who is the most likely to be the last
one standing nick offerman
also he has great survival skills yeah
but if he didn't sacrifice himself
or if we didn't sacrifice him i think
definitely but i agree i agree yeah
right yeah
no maybe luis because he's too smart as
well he will find ways no no way he's
probably me because i will be
sacrificing everyone else and then
you're the last one
yeah i knew it but i wouldn't let you
sacrifice yeah that should actually be a
slasher movie twist like
you think that someone is like the final
character but then it's revealed that
they've just been sacrificing everybody
else the entire time i have one last one
for you i like this one a lot too
who is the most likely to be the one
that you think is dead but then they
come back at the last possible second
and save the day
i think ben
yeah i think people thought he was dead
a lot of the time we were there
[Music] [Applause]
ben gets himself into some weird
situations i found myself in a situation
where some guy came up with like to us
talking to us while we were at the beach
with like a machete and ben was just
like trying to like talk it but it was a
wild wild ride so ben yeah ben he's so
funny he just gives off that energy to
find himself him i have to let you all
go thank you for your show and thank you
for amusing me with my slasher movie
obsession that was fun congratulations
and to everybody out there keep an eye
out for the resort trust me you have no
idea what you're in for
you